الزعيم الكوري الشمالي كيم جونج
اون يجب ان تتصف بصفاته او
بانها في حال شنت ضربة عسكرية
استباقية على اي هدف في الشمال
اطلاق الصواريخ النووية بتفويض
من المجنون. فهل تستفز سيول يو
فان بيونج يانج ستستخدم السلاح
النووي للقضاء على الجيش الكوري
موقفها اذا ارادت تجنب كارثة.
لكن يو جونج عادت واستدركت
الامريكية فقط. اذ عندما اطلق
وزير الدفاع الكوري الجنوبي
بالنوم مطمئنين للسنوات الاربع
المقبلة الافضل من البداية عدم
بجو بايدن رئيسا للولايات
المتحدة. وقالت اذا كنتم ترغبون
تعلن كوريا الشمالية حتى اطلاق
هذه التهديدات اعترافها رسميا
وفي العام الفين وخمسة عشر اعلن
زواجها من احد ابناء الطبقة
مفاوضات السلام مع جارتهم
الجنوبية. في عام الفين واثني
الاختبار. عامان كاملان اجتاز
فيهما ثلاثون شخصا ذلك الاختبار.
في البلاد التي اسسها جدها كيم
اولسونج. المرأة الحديدية التي
التصويت في الجمعية الشعبية
العليا. تم تعيينها كمسؤول كبير
جونج اون عن الانظار لعدة جدلا
واسعا حول صحته ومن قد يصلح
الخارج معا ما ساعد على توثيق
صلات الاخوة بينه فقد درس
اون حيث قضى جونغ اون ويو جونغ
الكثير من طفولتهما المنعزلة في
بعد ان ورث شقيقها السلطة عقب
وفاة والدهما عام الف واحد عشر.
علامات الحزن. تبدل الحال من
النقيض الى النقيض تماما بعد
علاقة وثيقة واستثنائية بشقيقها
وزعيم كوريا الشمالية كيم جونغ
ال وتلقت تعليمها في سويسرا مع
شقيقها. وتدرجت بسرعة في الرتب
ان تريح بالك من هذا كله فلا
تقترب من عائلة المجانين هذه ولا
يحتاج الى العقل وليس كل
المجانين مثل الا شقيقته فقد
جونج اكثر لتريهم ما يمكنها ان
تفعل? كي تكون ذا مكانة في دولة
الموقف بحكمة وقالت ان كوريا
الشمالية لن تكون البادئة في
الخوف على امنها من دون داعم.
لكن الفتاة التي تتصف بالجنون لم
الكورية. واضافت ان كوريا
الجنوبية يمكن ان تواجه تهديدا
تجاه الادارة الامريكية الجديدة
مع قيام واشنطن وسي اول بمناورات
خطورة العلاقات بين الكوريتين
والتوتر العسكري في شبه الجزيرة
التسبب باعمال تجعلكم تصابون
بالارق. ويتزامن هذا التصعيد
عشر طرحت يو جونغ شروطا ومواصفات
خاصة لفتى احلامها وبدأ
كاعدام زوج عمتها وكذلك اعدام
معارضي شقيقها وهي صاحبة قرار
الحاكمة لكن لم يتم اظهار زوجها
للعلن. وبعد ذلك بعام انجبت منه
الاوحد لشقيقها المجنون ويقال ان
من املت عليه معظم قراراته
حسب بعض التقارير تآمرت كيم يو
جونج مع اقصاء شقيقهما الاكبر من
ولا تغفر الاخطاء. تصدر احكام
الاعدام اكثر مما تتكلم. فبعد
تظهر امام الاعلام كمحب للخير
وصانعة للسلام. لكنها تظهر خلف
لاختيار زوجها وشريك حياتها.
ماذا? نعم كذلك عن اقوى امرأة في
الكواليس كاعاشقة لتنفيذ حكم
الاعدام وصارمة حازمة لا ترحم
باللجنة المركزية لحزب العمال
الكوري. اما في اكتوبر عام الفين
يأخذون بعضا فقط من جنون هذه
الفتاة وشقيقها ليقيفوا والغرب
افكار شقيقته فاذا دخلت دولة
المجنون فعليك ان تجن. واذا اردت
فاقته جنونا. بل ان البعض يصف
اعمال الزعيم المجنونة انها من
تنصب لهم العداء. والا فلن ينفعك
الجنون حينها. وليت القادة العرب
الخارطة وشقيقها الزعيم يخالف
لها طلبا. وهي كذلك امينة سر زر
تمتلك اسلحة نووية فتاكة
بامكانها ان تمحو دولا من
تكتفي بذلك. وهددت كوريا
الجنوبية بشكل مباشر مر اخرى.
الكمبيوتر في بيونج يانج. منحها
شقيقها المجنون منصبا تحت اشراف
بذلك اول عضو في الاسرة الحاكمة
لكوريا الشمالية تطأ قدمه الجنوب
منذ الحرب الكورية. علاقتها
بالمجنون. تجمع كيم يو جونج
الى دورة الالعاب الاوليمبية
الشتوي الفين وثمانية عشر لتصبح
بطريقة اسهل يجب ان تكون مجنونا.
والجنون كما يقول المثل العربي
واصغرهم يرعب الدول وما يثير
الخوف اكثر ان هذه المجنونة
الجنوبي. عائلة المجانين لا
تمزح. فاكبرهم ارهب العالم
الشمالي بان خطابه غير المسئول
واللاذع عن الضربات الوقائية زاد
خطيرا بسبب تصريحات وزير دفاعها
غير المسئولة. وينبغي ان تصحح
الازمة بين الكوريتين. تهديدات
يو جونغ لم تكن للولايات المتحدة
يقاتل بعضهم بعضا. معربة ايضا عن
املها في ان تتوقف سيئول عن
اطلاق حتى رصاصة واحدة على كوريا
الجنوبية لانها لا تعتبرها هدفا
لقواتها المسلحة وذلك لان مواطني
البلدين هم امة واحدة ولا يجب ان
تصريحاته ان بلاده تمتلك صواريخ
قادرة على اصابة اي هدف في كوريا
الشمالية بدقة وسرعة جاءه الرد
من المجنونة شقيقة الزعيم
جانبها من الحدود لكن يو جونج
لعبت دورا رئيسيا خلال هذه
اعتلائها منصبا عاليا في الدولة
سارعت الى اعدام زملائها في
عسكرية سنوية مشتركة. قامت كوريا
الشمالية بتفجير اتصال مشترك عند
اعدام الاشخاص الذين ينامون
اثناء خطابات شقيقها. تعتبر يو
النساء التي تقود كوريا الشمالية
مخالفة بذلك الاعراف والتقاليد
الجنوبية بعدم نشر رائحة البارود
من جديد في اراضيها بينما لم
الا ما ذكرناه. فيا ترى اي حياة
يعيش زوجها في المنزل. تهديد
الزوجة لتنفق عليه وعلى طفلهما.
حياة شخصية لا يعرف عنها الكثير
لامريكا. اطلقت الفتاة الحديدية
تهديداتها لامريكا وكوريا
في الساحة الكورية عام الفين
وعشرين عندما اثار اختفاء كيم
كوريا الشمالية وربما في العالم
نتحدث وللقصة بقية. ولدت يو جونغ
دون منافس. وكان ذلك تمهيدا
لشقيقته لتكون الزعيمة الاولى من
وسيم وحسن المظهر. ذكي ولبق
ويتمتع بصحة جيدة. هذا ليس
معا. لكن بالمقابل فهي من طرحت
اختبار الرجل الانسب طويل القامة
طفلها الوحيد ويبدو ان في هذه
القصة وربة المنزل. بينما تعمل
جونغ مهندسة لقاء شقيقها بالرئيس
الامريكي ترامب. وهي تقود
واربعة عشر فقيل انها ربما تكون
قد تولت مهام الدولة لشقيقها
المدرسة الذين لم يروقوا لها.
خصوصا بعد استلام شقيقها الحكم
الحكم واتهمته يو جونغ بادمان
المخدرات. يو جونغ هي المستشار
لكنها لم تظهر في التقارير
الاخبارية. تم ذكرها رسميا لاول
لخلافته ليكون ظهور اسم كيم يو
جونغ في مقدمة المرشحين بل لربما
المريض اثناء خضوعه للعلاج
الطبي. وهو الامر ذاته الذي طرح
مرة في التاسع من مارس عام الف
واربعة عشر حيث رافقت شقيقها في
للميلاد قبل ان تعود كيم يو جونغ
وتدرس البكالوريوس في علوم
اعلانا لوظيفة او مسابقة اوسم
رجل. انه اختبار شقيقة المجنون
لجنة الدفاع الوطني بداية عام
الفين واثني عشر كمديرة للسياحة.
الشقيقان معا في سويسرا بين عامي
الف وتسعمائة وستة وتسعين والفين
التليفزيون الحكومي تقف خلف كيم
جونغ اون مباشرة وتبدو عليها
كان وجودها يكاد لا يذكر حتى
جنازة والدها حين ظهرت في
عام الف وتسعمائة وثمانية
وثمانين بحسب بعض التقارير وهي
احد ثلاثة ابناء ولدوا لزعيم
كوريا الشمالية السابق كيم جونغ
قليلة الكلام كثيرة الافعال.
توصف بالجنون. مهندسة سياسات
ظلت الفتاة مختفية لسنوات.
وعندما ظهرت امسكت بدفة القيادة.
سنوات. حين ظهرت على وجهها
ابتسامة غامضة عندما كانت فوق
سلم متحرك في مطار انتشون في
كوريا الجنوبية كمبعوث لشقيقها
شقيقها. والشخصية الاقرب لخلافته
في البلاد. صاحبة قرارات ذات
المجنون والاكثر جنونا منه
والاقرب اليه من الاسرة الحاكمة.
الفتاة الحديدية اقوى النساء
نفوذا في كوريا الشمالية شقيقة
الوجه المرعب في كوريا الشمالية.
هددت امريكا وكوريا الجنوبية
ويحافظوا على كرامة وسيادة
شعوبهم.